So another type of report I'd like us to take a look at, is the drug
metabolism reports. because from those we can learn
how your body will react to particular drugs.
>> So, when you say drugs, do you
mean, like, prescription drugs or, like, other things, too?
>> Yes, prescription drugs, but we can also learn
how we expect your body to react to substances
such as alcohol and caffeine. So why don't we
go take a look at your caffeine and metabolism results?
>> Okay
>> so then we go to My Results again, and then go on Drug Response.
Click Drug Response and we'll see a list of reports and if we scroll down a bit
>> Oh caffeine metabolism.
>> Yeah, click on the one that says caffeine metabolism. We see here that
for the particular SNV that's important here,
you have, your homozygous for the a allele.
>> That means I'm a fast caffeine metabolizer, so if
I drink coffee it didn't increase the subjects heart attack risk.
>> Right, And basically that means you metabolize caffeine quickly and
the caffeine doesn't build up in your body as, as much.
>> It says here that I'm a fast caffeine metabolizer drinking
coffee here in the study didn't increase the subject's heart attack risk.
>> Okay, yes you have
the A version at this SNV and that it means you
have a version the metabolizing enzyme
that breaks down the caffeine efficiently.
>> So, if I'm a fast metabolizer of caffeine, would
the effects of caffeine last longer or shorter for me?